France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe sur France 24 et Radio
France Internationale en cette semaine
où les combats font rage en Ukraine
autour de darkmouth et où la région de
bérogrotte côté rue s'est en état
d'urgence les 27 mettent en route un 11e
train de sanction contre Moscou et nous
recevons pour en parler la présidente de
la sous-commission défense au Parlement
européen Nathalie Loiseau bonjour
bonjour nous sommes à quelques mètres de
l'hémicycle vous êtes député européenne
pour le groupe Rignoux et vous étiez
précédemment donc la ministre des
affaires européennes sur le premier
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron on va dire nous
allons parler bien sûr de cette guerre
mais pour commencer j'aimerais que vous
nous disiez un mot d'un autre sujet qui
vous tient particulièrement à coeur vous
êtes rapporteur sur le catargate c'est
ce grand scandale de corruption qui a
éclaté au sein de ce Parlement si
personne impliquées qui sont d'ailleurs
désormais en liberté est-ce que vous
recommandez
des des éléments qui vont mettre fin à
ces pratiques pour le moins douteuses de
façon assez définitive alors ce qu'on a
appelé le catarget c'est l'autre guerre
si j'ose dire c'est la guerre
d'influence et d'ingérence que nous mène
à un certain nombre de pays on appelle
ça le catarget mais depuis des années la
Russie la Chine et d'autres
essayent d'influencer la manière dont
nous prenons nos décisions dans les
institutions européennes et notamment au
Parlement européen ça a pris dans le cas
qui nous occupe une tournure très
particulière celle de la corruption
présumée présumée puisque
une décision de justice a pas encore été
rendue mais de plusieurs députés ou
anciens députés européens ça peut
prendre d'autres formes ce qu'on peut
empêcher les gens d'être corrompus non
parce que c'est déjà illégal c'est pas à
moi de réécrire le code pénal en
revanche on doit faire deux choses que
je propose dans mon rapport beaucoup
plus de transparence là où les choses
étaient trop opaques et beaucoup plus de
protection du travail des députés face à
des pays tiers parfois pas très
bienveillants qui veulent se mêler de ce
que nous faisons plus de transparence
c'est quoi en France on a la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique qui enquête
autorité la même indépendante et pour
les trois institutions alors moi je
demande aux politiques de monde très
clairement une haute autorité éthique
indépendante européenne qui est pouvoir
sur toutes les institutions pouvoir
d'enquête et
je suis inquiète de ce que j'entends
alors la Commission n'a pas encore fait
sa proposition mais je suis
objectivement inquiète et le rapport que
je présente à mes collègues et très
ferme sur nos attentes parce que ce sont
les attentes de nos concitoyens la
confiance que nous donne les électeurs
on doit la mériter et pour les mériter
on doit être transparent par exemple
pouvoir donner notre patrimoine au début
de notre mandat et à la fin comme ça
s'il y a enregistrement obligatoire des
réunions entre les groupes d'intérêts et
les euros députés ça ça n'est déjà plus
à l'ordre du jour si mais il faut que ce
soit appliqué parce qu'il y a des règles
mais certaines n'étaient pas appliquées
et une fausse ONG qui a été l'espèce de
cheval de Troie de ce fameux catarget
comment se fait-il qu'elle avait en
quelque sorte table ouverte au Parlement
européen moi ce que je souhaite par
exemple quand j'écris un rapport j'en
écrirais un bientôt sur la Syrie je
publierai en annexe la liste de tous les
gens que j'ai rencontré je dois être
capable de justifier qui je vois et
pourquoi je le vois de toute façon je le
fais déjà toutes les semaines sur les
réseaux sociaux je publie mon agenda
complet parce que je le dois
et sanctionner si ça n'est pas fait
évidemment revenons si vous le est bien
Nathalie Loiseau sur une série
d'élections qui vont changer la face de
l'Europe on commence évidemment par la
Turquie contre toute attente le
président sortant c'est qualifié premier
l'ultra nationaliste sinacorgan a
annoncé d'ailleurs qu'il soutiendra
réchauffe tail pairsoan
une victoire de l'opposition pour vous
n'est plus possible et puis est-ce que
elle c'était le meilleur scénario pour
l'Union européenne alors je ne sais pas
ce qui va se passer si on regarde les
sondages si on regarde l'avance de
réceptaï hyperdogan il semble il sera
réélu je me demande si on n'a pas eu un
biais en regardant cette élection turque
regardez aussi tout ce qu'on a lu et
entendu sur l'élection grecque certains
nous disons Syriza revient au pouvoir
aujourd'hui or c'est le PPE le PPE le
parfait de la Crau le Premier ministre
grec à une avance phénoménale donc
parfois certains voient le monde tel que
il leur plairait de le voir
plutôt que tel qu'il est ce que ça dit
si récepté par Logan et réélu c'est que
les choix démocratiques de la Turquie
continue de l'éloigner de l'Union
européenne parce que récepta hyperdogan
a fait un choix qui semble être validé
par ces électeurs
il n'y a pas de pluralisme des médias
aussi forts de restriction des libertés
vous avez des opposants en prison vous
avez des journalistes en prison vous
avez des fonctionnaires qui ont été soit
renvoyés soit mis en prison vous n'avez
pas une liberté d'expression en Turquie
comme vous l'avez dans l'Union
européenne
vous n'avez pas de pluralisme des médias
comme nous pouvons la voir bref
la candidature entre guillemets de la
Turquie à l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne est un mythe un mythe qui est
encore entretenu par les autorités
turques qui n'ont pas le courage de dire
qu'elles ont fait un autre choix moi je
le respecte cette autre choix il faut
arrêter de se raconter des histoires
autre exélection où on va essayer de pas
se raconter d'histoires non plus celle
des européennes ont lieu dans un an pile
du 6 au 9 juin 2024
avec des sondages qui donnent en tête à
nouveau là le Parti populaire européen
et peut-être d'ailleurs en troisième
position il voudrait faire faire
alliance avec la première ministre
italienne Georgia Meloni et son groupe
euro-sceptique ECR au Parlement qui
serait au coup d'accouche d'ailleurs
avec votre groupe pour la troisième
position réunion est-ce que cette grande
alliance de la droite y compris jusqu'à
la droite plus extrême et souhaitable en
tout cas vous voudriez participer alors
sûrement pas sûrement pas et je vais pas
parler à la place du PPE donc le groupe
de centres droits ils sont assez grands
pour parler eux-mêmes ce que j'entends
de beaucoup de membres du PPE c'est que
beaucoup sont troublé par ces signaux un
peu ambigu que donne certains au PPE de
proximité avec Madame mélony un peu à
l'image de ce qu'on voit dans le
gouvernement italien où vous avez
Antonio taiani PPE dans du Parlement du
Parlement européen berlusconis pour
faire court dans le gouvernement de
Madame Meloni Fratelli Italia dont
l'héritage néo fasciste est quand même
très très ambigu et avec la Ligue de
Matteo Salvini
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de gens au
PPE qui ne souhaitent pas
sa coquiner de cette manière-là avec la
droite la plus extrême
s'agissant de ce que vous dites des
sondages c'est-à-dire que oui you le
groupe auquel j'appartiens et qui est le
troisième groupe du Parlement européen
le groupe pivot sans lequel les
majorités ne peuvent pas se faire
au coût d'un coup avec le groupe qu'on
dit des conservateurs mais on trouve des
gens assez radicaux comme Madame Meloni
comme Vox en Espagne etc etc moi je
trouve que c'est un encouragement à ne
pas s'endormir sur nos lauriers et de ne
pas être dans notre zone de confort
on a fait beaucoup de choses depuis
quatre ans au Parlement européen je
crois que beaucoup de gens nous le
reconnaissent ici on a porté beaucoup de
transformations mais on n'est jamais
réélu sur un bilan il faut continuer à
être crédible à être au contact étroit
de nos concitoyens et si ça peut être
quelque part un électroshock tant mieux
alors d'ailleurs le président de
l'Assemblée nationale Richard Ferrand
vous verrez bien vous Nathalie Loiseau
tête de liste de la République en marche
pour ces prochaines élections européen
vous aussi écoutez moi je suis ici en
train de faire ce que j'ai à faire vous
l'avez dit je préside la sous-commission
de la défense je reviens de Moldavie
j'étais en Ukraine je peux vous dire que
mes journées sont assez bien remplies et
que j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir
terminé ce que je souhaite c'est me
représenter je suis pas la seule et
d'autres dont certainement venir mais
j'estime que ce que j'ai pu commencer à
faire il faut le terminer parce que
c'est ce que je dois à mes concitoyens
qui sera juste je n'en sais rien
ce qui est important et ce qui est déjà
un message très fort en soi c'est que la
majorité présidentielle va partir unie
qu'on soit Renaissance anciennement en
marche qu'on soit modem ou qu'on soit
horizon ce qui est mon cas aujourd'hui
on sait pas très bien ce qui va se
passer à gauche avec la nuque on a
plutôt l'impression qu'il va pas y avoir
de liste unique mais on ne sait pas à
l'extrême droite on entend que il y aura
une liste rassemblement nationale mais
aussi une liste reconquête les seuls qui
peuvent dire aujourd'hui nous partons
Unis parce que nous avons les mêmes
convictions et la même envie de faire
progresser l'Europe au profit de nos
concitoyens c'est la majorité
présidentielle alors Emmanuel Macron
justement a parlé d'une pause dans la
réglementation écologiste la France se
range même parmi les pays qui demandent
à revoir cette ces normes automobiles de
plus en plus drastiques qui sont
demandées est-ce que c'est votre message
à la jeunesse pour 2024 qu'il faut moins
d'écologie alors il faut sûrement pas
moins d'AC mais il faut simplement
pouvoir digérer ce qu'on est en train
d'adopter le Green Deal le pacte vert
c'est extraordinairement ambitieux c'est
très large ça touche beaucoup de
secteurs et il faut que la société les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs les
industriels les consommateurs puissent
avancer au rythme des nouvelles normes
que on leur propose le but c'est pas
d'être moins ambitieux c'est de le
rendre acceptable c'est de ne pas sortir
de la route au motif que on conduirait
trop vite et que les passagers
n'auraient pas bien compris la direction
l'Ukraine bien sûr gros dossier il ne
reste rien de barmouth selon Monsieur
Zelinski Président on parle aussi de
cette région russe de Belgorod qui avec
des incursions de quoi ces deux villes
finalement sont le nom aujourd'hui
Nathalie Loiseau
du fait que c'est une guerre longue
difficile
dont l'issue dépendra beaucoup de nous
j'entends en Europe certains qui disent
faudrait que ça se termine plus vite
qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire qu'on
ferait pression
faire pression sur la lumière Poutine on
le fait par les sanctions pour le moment
on n'a pas convaincu d'arrêter une
guerre qu'on ne veut pas qu'il gagne
faire pression sur
le feu bricoler une situation
d'entre-deux ce qu'on a appelé d'un
terme que je déteste un conflit gelé le
conflit il est pas gelé il est oublié
par ceux qui feraient mieux le sang
préoccuper on l'a fait en 2015 avec les
accords de Minsk ça a permis à la Russie
de reculer pour mieux sauter ce qu'il
faut c'est mettre en place une paix
durable et ce qu'il faut c'est avoir
durablement
dissuader la Russie de son aventurisme
militaire qui menace note
sanction qui touche les compagnies
russes mais aussi un peu les compagnies
chinoises un peu aussi les diamants
c'est ça qui fait la différence moi je
trouve et le Parlement européen dans son
écrasante majorité trouve qu'on est trop
lent et pas assez ambitieux trop lent
c'est le fait de devoir se mettre
d'accord à 27 pour chacun des une
sanctions et en ce moment c'est la
Hongrie de Victor Hormann qui ralentit
le processus on sait que Victor urban
est assez proche de Vladimir Poutine et
qu'il est très mécontent parce qu'une
banque hongroise a été désignée pour sa
proximité avec la Russie et on bloque en
fait
il ralentit le financement militaire et
ralentit le l'adoption du prochain
paquet de sanctions ce qui est bien et
là où je salue sur l'avant-dernière
c'est d'être allé regarder ces trous
dans la raquette c'est ces entreprises y
compris européenne qui continuait à être
un peu des profiteurs de guerre du côté
russe sans trop le dire elle commence à
les pointer du doigt alors évidemment ça
grince et ça coince mais elle a raison
parce que toujours plus de sanctions
faisons déjà en sorte qu'elle soit mieux
appliquées c'est aussi ce que disent les
Britanniques avec qui je travaille
beaucoup c'est aussi ce que disent les
Américains essayons de verrouiller le
système pas pour mettre la Russie à
genoux mais pour mettre l'effort de
guerre russes à genoux alors
en Ukraine plus de 170 000 kilomètres
carrés et de terre serait désormais
contaminé par des mines et munitions non
explosées une surface plus de 4 fois
supérieure à la Suisse 7 millions
d'hectares donc de terre ne pourront pas
être en semencés cette année nous
partons tout de suite en direction du
sud à la rencontre des agriculteurs
Ukrainiens qui ont vu et rencontrer
notre envoyé spécial là-bas Johan Bodin
à travers champ c'est un chapelet mortel
qui s'égraine dans les prairies du sud
de l'Ukraine
du haut-bômes rirka a été pendant trois
mois sur la ligne de front ou un mot
leur est à la reconstruction
Ivan et sa famille possède 700 hectares
son cheptel a été volé pendant les six
mois d'occupation russe et les combats
qui ont permis la libération de la
région de Carson ont laissé sur son
exploitation des carcasses calcinées des
caisses de munitions et des champs se
mélangent de mort comme nombre
d'agriculteurs Ukrainiens ils se
débrouille par lui-même quitte à déminer
de façon artisanale
nous avons acheté des détecteurs de
métaux et nous avons marché à plusieurs
à travers nos champs séparés de 5 6
mètres et nous continuons à le faire
quand nous sommes face à des obus de
tank ou des roquettes grades au sol ce
n'est pas aussi dangereux que là où ils
ont posé des mines antichard
Yvan et ses amis font le tri entre les
obus et ventes et ceux non explosé
quitte parfois des miner à mains nues
la moitié de cet air serait désormais
selon lui dépolluer prête pour Kandra il
ouvriers sème des cultures tardives
voilà les graines de tournesol acheter à
crédit un pari sur l'avenir pour espérer
que 15 mois de guerre finissent enfin
d'altérer le rythme des récoltes
pouvaient être déminées cet été car
c'est automne nous devons planter de
nouveau
et dans un ou deux ans les mines vont
s'enfoncer plus profondément dans le sol
et alors quand serons-nous capables de
déminer
mais tout ce n'osent pas comme ils vont
retourner aux champs les trois quarts
des surfaces des environs resteront en
jachère
Nathalie Loiseau dans ce reportage on
voit d'ailleurs ce sud un tiers des
terres avec des mines effectivement une
agriculture qui est à l'arrêt dans
toutes ces régions qui ont été des zones
de combat c'est un drame pour l'Ukraine
mais c'est un drame pour le monde c'est
le grenier du monde l'Ukraine et vous
connaissez les efforts qui sont faits
manière internationale et notamment
européenne pour sortir les céréales du
crâne mais en effet le défi du déminage
est considérable merci Nathalie l'oiseau
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui on
continue avec Public Sénat ici même sur
ce plateau je vais être rejoint pas ma
conso pour parler précisément
d'agriculture européenne et de blé
ukrainien tout de suite c'est le débat
de France 24 et Public Sénat
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre ici depuis le
Parlement à Bruxelles pour débattre d'un
objet de discorde entre les 27 le blé
ukrainien la colère gronde dans les
campagnes voisines polonaises bulgares
roumaine slovaque et hongroise ou les
céréales ukrainiennes ont envahi les
marchés nationaux et fait baisser les
prix au lieu d'être exportés dans leur
intégralité comme prévu par les pays
africains pour tenter de calmer la
fronde des agriculteurs des pays de
l'est et les reprendre les exportations
la Commission européenne s'est engagée à
dédommager les plaintifs à hauteur de
156 millions d'euros financés notamment
par la PAC un geste financier un peu
paradoxal quand même au moment où les
Ukrainiens souffrent dans leur chair de
la guerre et que les pertes pour les
entreprises agricoles s'élèvent à 3,8
milliards d'euros pour eux il est vrai
que le grenier à blé de l'Europe qui est
l'Ukraine inquiète dans la perspective
de l'adhésion plusieurs pays européens
dont la France car Kiev deviendrait
premier Béné de la politique agricole
communale alors l'Union européenne
a-t-elle gérée ce dossier céréalier pour
garantir que les exportations
ukrainiennes au pays tiers arrivent bien
à destination malgré le blocage de la
mer Noire par les Russes l'unité des 27
est-elle en cause dans ce dossier nous
en parlons aujourd'hui avec deux invités
de la chienne Cholo merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes l'ancien commissaire
européen chargé de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui euro député pour le groupe
réunion et puis face à vous Anna de
parney greenenberg bonjour vous êtes
heureux député les Verts allemande on va
démarrer expliquer nous un peu de
pédagogie à l'origine ce mécanisme de
corridor d'exportation des céréales
viser à rendre à nouveau possible les
exportations de l'Ukraine vers les pays
africains et ce notamment afin d'éviter
une crise alimentaire on parle de 23
millions de tonnes exportés qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé et bien l'Union
européenne bien sûr avait une grande
responsabilité
comme tous ensemble nous voulons
soutenir l'Ukraine quand nous avons vu
que bien sûr les ports d'exportation
étaient bloqués par par les Russes et
par la guerre il fallait trouver des
solutions par contre dans une situation
extrême comme ça de Christ ce n'est pas
si simple donc nous avons essayé de la
voie ferroviaire essayer aussi de
rejoindre par la Roumanie de nouveau la
mer Noire plusieurs choses ont été mis
en place aussi des façons de stocker par
contre bien sûr dans le stockage il faut
faire attention à la qualité du blé ce
qui est difficile aussi au bout d'un
certain temps et pour résumer l'Union
européenne était de bonne volonté par
contre on a vraiment eu le problème
c'est que la vente après ne s'est pas
avéré si simple car il n'y avait pas de
contrat à long terme c'est-à-dire pour
expliquer un peu pour faire simple
beaucoup de bateaux Ukrainiens partaient
en fait vers la Libye ou l'Afrique et
vendait en fait sur place et maintenant
qui doit reprendre en fait ce mécanisme
de vente donc les céréales arrivent
logiquement dans les pays on va dire
avoisinant l'Ukraine exactement
limitrophes mais après qui qui fait en
fait et là on est en train de mettre en
place le plus vite possible c'est pour
bien sûr l'économie ukrainienne en
elle-même mais aussi pour que le blé
comme denrées alimentaires arrivent
aussi à destination et ne déstabilise
pas comme complètement les marchés
nationaux européens l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions comme on dit H&M solos
rappelle que vous êtes roumain pourquoi
ce beau projet initial donc a-t-il
suscité la colère des agriculteurs des
pays limitrophes qui étaient pourtant
d'ailleurs soutien géopolitique très
fort de l'Ukraine l'objectif de l'Union
européenne était très beau très bon dès
le départ d'aider l'Ukraine à exporter
les céréales sauf que la seule décision
qui a été prise pour faire ça c'était
d'ouvrir le marché européenne les
frontières européennes éliminaient
toutes quota pour que toutes les
quantités de céréales ukrainiennes et
axé sur le marché européen dans l'idée
que elles vont faire que transiter le
problème c'est que elles n'ont pas que
transitaire le territoire européenne des
quantités importantes arrêtez sur le
territoire européenne pourquoi pour des
questions de marché simples le bleu
ukrainienne est moins cher que le bleu
européenne donc les éleveurs de l'Union
européenne ont préféré le bleu
ukrainiennes au bleu européenne qui
était moins cher donc les silos des
États membres de la frontière avec le
grain ce sont restés plein avec les
céréales locaux qui n'ont pas pu être
vendus parce que leur prix était plus
élevé et en fait on a dit qu'on va créer
ce couloirs de transit sur le territoire
européen mais des facto cela ne s'est
pas passé on n'a pas des moyens pour
l'instant la Commission européenne n'a
pas mis en place des moyens pour faire
la différence entre les céréales qui
devrait être transitaire l'Union
européenne et les céréales qui
s'arrêtent sur le territoire de l'Union
Européenne et alors justement l'une des
solutions pour le moment apportées par
la Commission européenne et bien ça a
été de débloquer en mars via la Pâques
56 millions d'euros pour dédommager les
agriculteurs et laisse une deuxième
enveloppe de 100 millions d'euros à deux
nouveaux été débloqués il y a quelques
semaines Alain de Barney Groenenberg
est-ce qu'on peut dire finalement
Bruxelles achète la paix sociale sans
résoudre le problème sur le fond je ne
dirai pas ça de manière si brute les
mesures étaient importantes pour les
agriculteurs sur place par contre il
faut travailler encore plus sur
l'évacuation justement dans les pays
destinataires et là nous avons l'idée de
passer peut-être même par les pays
baltes pour arriver à des nouveaux ports
pour que puisse vraiment sortir en fait
les quantités de blé qui sont
nécessaires dans d'autres parties du
monde donc en fait tout le monde il y a
à gagner de ne pas laisser en fait ce
grain qui n'est pas forcément non plus
aux normes sanitaires ou au niveau des
phytosanitaires comme nous l'avons au
niveau de l'Union européenne donc tout
le monde y a à gagner l'Union européenne
a dû mettre ses enveloppes en place pour
réétablir un peu on va dire la paix
sociale à mon avis ce n'était peut-être
face à une situation d'urgence
exactement et dans une situation de
guerre il faut quand même le dire ce ne
sont pas des stratégies en fait qui sont
bien travaillées à l'avance il faut y
aller du jour au lendemain par contre là
il faut vraiment travailler rapidement
pour qu'on puisse avoir justement comme
le disait monsieur cholos un transit le
problème qui s'est passé en Roumanie
mais aussi en Hongrie en Pologne dans
ces pays limitrophes c'est on a bloqué
finalement à la frontière c'est céréales
on a on a bloqué le blé le maïs
ukrainien dans les silos est-ce que
c'est une sorte de prise de prise en
otage je vous parliez de de politisation
de ce problème en quelque sorte on les a
pas bloqué de manière institutionnelles
mais ceux qui ont acheté des céréales en
Ukraine les ont vendus sur le territoire
ou même polonais hongrois ainsi de suite
parce qu'ils ont trouvé un marché parce
que on n'avait pas prévu
institutionnellement le transit jusqu'au
bout ma proposition ça a été dès le
départ qu'on
qu'on accompagne ces transports de
rectificat d'exportation des certificats
où on prévoit quels sont les transports
qui doivent que transiter l'Union
européenne pour que ça soit clair à la
douane qu'elles n'ont pas le droit
d'être déchargé sur le territoire
européenne et quels sont les quantités
qui s'arrêtent sur le territoire
européen pour connaître un contrôle des
de ces politisations vous dites de cette
politisation parce que tant que il y a
pas un contrôle de transit de ces
céréales nous on n'a pas des évidences
de quantités qui s'arrête sur le
territoire
de l'Union Européenne elles affectent le
marché locaux les producteurs locaux ne
sont pas dédommagés et donc les forces
d'extrême droite et anti-européenne ils
disent bah voilà ce qui vous fait
l'Union européenne avec le marché locaux
il y a autre chose dont on parlait Anna
de parler c'est que tous les pays
réfractaires dénonçables qui ne seraient
pas aux normes environnemental de
l'Union européenne car chargé de
pesticides est-ce que c'est c'est un
prétexte ou c'est une réalité écologique
il y a une législation européenne qui
doivent être respectées par tous les
produits qui rentrent sur le marché
européenne y compris les produits
ukrainiennes donc la législation est
très claire les autorités qui appliquent
cette législation ce sont les autorités
nationales les autorités nationales
phytosanitaires au sanitaires
vétérinaires ont l'obligation de
vérifier à l'entrée sur le territoire de
l'Union Européenne chaque quantité donc
là dessus si quelqu'un dit ça parce que
j'ai entendu aussi en Roumanie ailleurs
et je les ai envoyé aux autorités
nationales pour demander s'ils ont fait
la vérification ou pas normalement cette
vérification doit être fait croyez-vous
un dumping environnemental des blés maïs
finalement
Ukrainiens on n'a pas de preuve on va
dire claire là-dessus le problème
principal qu'on a c'est qu'on a vraiment
un marché on va dire aussi qui va
toujours vers le moins cher et qui crée
forcément donc en fait à une attraction
on va dire de doubler moins cher ou même
de tout maïs pour nourrir l'élevage donc
ça c'est un peu un problème de fond que
on essaye de régler ici quand on parle
de la pacte générale c'est-à-dire que si
on arrive avec aussi sur du spéculation
sur sur la nourriture et sur en fait un
élevage qui va toujours essayer d'avoir
le la nourriture la moins chère possible
pour l'élevage pour pouvoir après vendre
le moins cher possible la viande sur le
marché européen on a vraiment en fait on
attire en fait justement ce genre ce
genre de procédure c'est-à-dire que dès
que c'est arrivé donc les pays d'un côté
ont voulu aider en même temps le marché
a attiré en fait ces céréales et on n'a
pas réussi à faire inflation en Europe
donc les lois du marché ont fait que ça
n'a pas été vraiment pensé on va dire
c'était parti d'une bonne volonté mais
ça a pas été pensé jusqu'au bout et
maintenant nous avons les problèmes
vraiment réels et comme le disait
monsieur Cholot c'est aussi une grande
campagne contre l'Union européenne
contre en fait la malgérence alors qu'en
fait on va dire tous les 27 membres sont
aussi de la partie par rapport à ça je
vais juste mentionner ceux qui disent
qu'ils peuvent régler ce problème au
niveau national les Polonais les
Hongrois les bulgares qui ont fermé au
niveau national la frontière ils font du
populisme ils m'ont les agriculteurs ils
peuvent pas contrôler sur un marché
commun européen ce problème au niveau
national il faut s'ajoute pour vendre à
l'électoral l'idée on va s'occuper de
vous parce que l'Europe n'est pas
capable on va se protéger et tout fermer
l'ONU c'est pas possible sur un marché
commun s'il sera ne rentre pas sur la
frontière polonaise
ukrainienne elle peut très bien rentrer
par les autres frontières européennes
parce que le marché européen est ouvert
l'ONU dans un rapport a déjà un signalé
que ces exportations de céréales
ukrainés n'ont finalement atterri dans
les pays riches comme l'Espagne l'Italie
les Pays-Bas et profiter seulement pour
un quart au pays pauvres comme l'Egypte
l'Iran le Bangladesh et le Soudan ce que
l'Union européenne s'est servi la
première au détriment de pays où la
famine get mais c'est pas une question
que l'Union européenne pas voulu se
servir pour ne pas les envoyer en
Afrique c'est une question de marché
ceux qui ont ces achats n'ont pas été
dirigés tous ces Allemands ce sont des
agents économiques qui ont acheté des
céréales et qui les ont vendus là où ils
ont trouvé du pouvoir politique européen
ça montre en fait le fait que nous avons
voulu aider les Ukrainiennes et c'est
très bien qu'on les aide mais on n'est
pas allé jusqu'au bout c'est cool lors
des transit elles existent en théorie
mais elles sont pas contrôlées
institutionnellement pour s'assurer que
le céréales qui rend sur le territoire
urbain sort aussi de territoire
voilà tout à fait mais on manque
d'autres choses donc ce qu'il faudrait
faire maintenant à mon avis c'est que la
Commission européenne ensemble avec les
États membres assume ses couloirs de
transit des facto c'est-à-dire
nous avons de toute façon une charge
aussi de reconstruire on va dire et on
veut accueillir aussi l'Ukraine de
l'Union européenne un jour donc en fait
il faut aussi penser par exemple au
ferroviaires il faut penser déjà à
l'avenir et donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose que l'Union européenne doit
maintenant prendre comme responsabilité
se poser la question comment on organise
le transit et pas seulement comment on
organise on va dire à court terme mais
quels sont aussi les implications on va
dire pour une politique industrielle
européenne qui peuvent amener du réseau
on va dire à tous les pays transit pour
l'avenir alors il y a un an tout juste
les 27 ont reconnu le statut de candidat
à l'adhésion de l'Ukraine avec 41
millions d'hectares de surfaces
agricoles c'est le plus gros évidemment
grenier à blé de l'Europe et ça inquiète
d'autres pays bénéficiaires de la
politique agricole commune la France la
Pologne et la Roumanie aussi est-ce que
son adhésion changerait effectivement
les règles du jeu et la répartition de
la politique agricole commune si
importante à mon avis en tant
qu’onciaire ministre de l'Agriculture de
notamment ancien commissaire européenne
avec l'actuel politique agricole commune
telle qu'elle est structurée maintenant
on ne peut pas intégrer l'Ukraine dans
l'Union européenne donc si on veut et on
le souhaite réintégrer l'Ukraine dans
l'Union européenne moi je suis un
farouche supporter de l'intégration de
pays des Balkans et de l'Ukraine de la
Moldavie à l'Union européenne mais si on
souhaite ça il faut d'abord réformer
réponse en fait non pas réformé réponse
et la politique agricole agroalimentaire
et environnemental européen c'est ça
vous serez d'accord de toute façon là on
se rejoint parce que pour refonder la
pacte nous sommes tout à fait d'accord
et bien sûr qu'il va falloir
jusqu'en 2027 bien sûr de toute façon le
processus de candidature il faut aussi
ça va ça va prendre du temps donc faut
être resté réaliste mais je pense que ça
peut être aussi on va dire un tremplin
positif pour repenser la Pâque par
rapport on va dire au bien commun quels
sont les facteurs de bien commun que
produisent les agriculteurs qu'est-ce
qu'il faut compenser comment les aider à
se transformer et bien sûr la paie à
l'hectare comme nous la voyons avec tous
les effets négatifs sur la biodiversité
sur les sols sur l'eau c'est un moment
on va dire une chance incroyable de
mettre ça en avant et de se poser la
question qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
Pâques qui serait plus apte on va dire
au combat de nos jours contre le climat
et contre la perte un bénéfice
d'intégrer un grand pays agricole
pourquoi pas bien sûr bien sûr que
pourquoi nous réjouissons pas d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est capable aussi de
produire de la nourriture ce n'est pas
avec le clan dans l'Union européenne
une région au monde encore plus
important sur le marché alimentaire
mondial donc elle peut elle aura encore
plus de poids pour faire émerger des
nouvelles règles au niveau international
mais ce qu'il faut être ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est pas que à cause de
l'Ukraine que nous on doit revoir la
politique agricole commune il y a
l'élargissement il y a la politique
environnementale il y a la vision
alimentaire de l'Union européenne tous
ces éléments ensemble doivent nous faire
réponser la politique publique
européenne sur l'agriculture
alimentation et l'environnement une
force mais ce dossier agricole épineux
aux multiples répercussions on l'a
compris pourrait quand même fragiliser
l'unité des 27 sur la question crinienne
c'est pour ça qu'il faut commencer à
discuter à l'avance et non pas laisser
jusqu'au moment où ça chauffe et ça
explose exactement et aussi voir
vraiment le positif parce que nous avons
rendu compte que être dépendant d'autres
pays cela à menuise notre pouvoir en
tant qu'Union européenne en agrandissant
là notre pouvoir on va dire de
souveraineté alimentaire nous pouvons
repenser certains standards et nous
l'avons vu dans beaucoup de domaines
quand l'Union européenne se met en route
de rependée repenser ses standards elle
peut avoir un poids sur les standards on
va dire aussi du marché international
investir faire entrer l'Ukraine dans
l'Union européenne il est clair que si
on pense au céréales ukrainien content
que matériel matière première ça peut
concurrencer des céréales françaises
espagnoles roumain ainsi de suite mais
si on investit dans notre capacité de
transformation l'Union européenne
exporte notamment de produits finis de
produits élaborés si on va penser
jusqu'au bout la chaîne alimentaire
alors là l'Europe peut sortir renforcée
merci à vous d'avoir en tout cas très
bien investi ce débat en notre compagnie
vous restez sur nos antennes pour la
suite des programmes
[Musique]